hello everybody my name is markiplier my
roommates are still asleep so I decided
that I was going to record a let's play
and make it the world's quietest let's
play so I thought what better game to
play then happy wheels and now I won't
move on to a sore throat
I will murder these sons of [ __ ] eat
a dick little Johnny eat ten dicks
why the [ __ ] did that happen you son of
a [ __ ] I will eat your face an epic big
ball throw because if there's one thing
that markiplier likes its epic big balls
I unlocked the win and I received
another ball an odd medical condition to
have an extra ball but one that I will
not complain about because I'm a winner
I'm not ready for a rope swing I was not
told that I was going to be doing a rope
swing I'm pretty sure this was not part
of my contract and frankly I hate
everything you stand for and everything
that you are suffering is all you will
get in this an area suffering is all you
will get because I don't know how to
[ __ ] talk Yoho oh my god [ __ ] me in
the puddle it sounds a lot more sexual
when I say it's closed
and this quietly [ __ ] me in the puddle
but not seriously like you know rayji
way [ __ ] the melon no don't [ __ ] the
mountain whenever I say something like
this it sounds very sexual do not [ __ ]
melons but you know [ __ ] the melon I
thank you everybody for joining me for
the world's cleanest let's play I hope
you enjoyed it
what is going on under the breech of my
friends remember pain is only a
temporary measure my [ __ ] yeah you
better move on don't you [ __ ] dare
you [ __ ] yeah tell me what voice
modulator that is please ladies cheers
but most of you love it up